one of the themes or strategies of the
Republican Party under the current
administration is projection right it's
accused others of doing what you do it's
a very common tactic but it's really
been sort of on steroids under the
current administration now this isn't
new they've been doing it for a long
time it's just taken on a particularly
sort of special significance under
Donald Trump Hillary's information
Security's terrible she can't be trusted
with with documents and classified
information Trump is using unsecured
phones that he refuses to have screened
and his family is using private email
for government business Oh projection
right Trump is going to stop cronyism
and he's going to drain the swamp and
then he hires half of his immediate
family and fills his cabinet with rich
cronies you get the idea but on the
Ukraine Joe Biden story they've actually
been doing one of the most acute
projection jobs that we've ever seen
Donald Trump and his family are self
enriching from the presidency but he
insists and he accuses Joe Biden and his
son hunter of self enriching from
Biden's former vice presidency Don jr.
went on TV like I told you last week and
said I wish I could make millions from
my dad's presidency talking about the
Biden's but of course Don Jr is making
millions from his dad's presidency only
the blindest loyalists could miss the
reality here or someone who's
cognitively limited and that wouldn't be
something to make fun of I mean if
that's the case then you wouldn't
necessarily understand the nuances of
what's going on and it has now been
scaled up once again to these cartoonish
levels with Donald Trump criticizing Joe
Biden for supposed Eartha collapses
involving helping his son hunter get a
privileged position while Trump is
simultaneously plugging Don Junior's new
book off of which he will of course make
a whole bunch of money Trump says Joe
Biden helped his son hunter make money
from Joe Biden's vice presidency as bad
it's corrupt it's terrible and then
Donald Trump tweets quote my son Don jr.
is coming out with a new book triggered
how the left thrives on hate and wants
to silence us available tomorrow no
member v a great book that I highly
recommend for all to read go order it
today first of all the idea of Don
junior writing a book is absolutely
hilarious and I'm going to get to that
in a second but this is Trump again
doing the thing he criticizes others for
if Trump were any other federal employee
but the president this would violate
ethics rules a Trump is using the
position of the presidency to benefit
his son financially exactly what he is
accusing Joe Biden of doing for Hunter
Biden now as far as Don Junior's book is
concerned I looked around to see whether
Don Jr really wrote it or whether it was
ghost written by someone who can
actually write there's no other name
listed on the book but I took one look
at the beginning and it's pretty damn
clearly written by Don junior because it
is some of the worst writing I've ever
seen let's check out an excerpt this is
just cringe-worthy bad writing chapter
one trigger warning I'm not mad
look everybody is called a traitor once
or twice in their lives right
everybody gets falsely accused and
wrongly investigated by the FBI and has
to testify in front of Congress for over
30 hours answering the same stupid
politically motivated questions over and
over again don't they and everybody has
an army of social justice warriors
combing through every word they've ever
said online to find something to be
offended by correct why should I be mad
I'm not mad
in fact my plan was to write a feel-good
book about forgiveness and healing sort
of a Chicken Soup for the political soul
type of story I was even going to call
it kumbaya instead of triggered but it
seemed that title was already taken
probably by one of the 2467 Democrat
candidates currently running for
president so instead of chicken soup
over the next 300 pages or so I'll take
you on a tour of all the craziest most
destructive ideas that the left has come
up with in the last decade or more think
of it as a trip through Jurassic Park
only instead of dangerous dinosaurs you
get to see sleepy liberal losers
socialist crybabies and hypocritical
politicians the media if you decide to
come along I promise that nothing will
jump into the car with us you'll also
get to find out a little about me during
the ride if only as a way to dispel the
conspiracy
on the left that I was born with horns
of course horns a known anti-semitic
trope I mean I hesitate to even bring it
up not suggesting that it's deliberate
just always seems to end up in there
doesn't it anyway can you imagine being
so confused about reality that in the
limited lifetime you have the number of
hours you have on this earth is ticking
down right you choose this as a book to
read and in truth no real readers would
read Don Jr's book it's just not the way
that things work this is not the type of
book you sell to people that read
regularly this is the type of book you
sell to people that don't read and are
going to buy it as a political statement
now as far as Donald Trump promoting the
book while criticizing Joe Biden Trump
has no ability to feel shame he has no
ability to understand irony he has no
ability to understand hypocrisy that's
not news that shouldn't surprise us
please if you have some other position
on buying this book and you plan to do
it I want to hear from you and I want to
know I want to know why quite frankly